Some new research shows that the secret to
being a creative genius might be being a bad
person.
Anthony Carboni here for DNews and it turns
out that creative people tend to be more dishonest
than others.
A 2011 study of employees at an ad agency
anonymously surveyed people in different departments
to see how likely they were to engage in questionable
behaviors at work like "take home office supplies"
and "inflate your expense report-" and people
in creative departments like copywriting and
design were way more likely to do dishonest
things than other employees.
Why?
Well, the idea is that creative behavior requires
you to break rules- to create something you
have to think outside of the normal boundaries
of every day life.
So people who are more likely to break those
every day rules are more likely to create
something that lies outside of them.
But wait- does that mean creative people are
more likely to lie, or that lying makes people
more creative?
Which comes first?
A new Harvard study says first comes lying,
then comes art.
And the less time between a lie and a creative
act, the more creative you'll be.
Five groups were tested for their baseline
level of creative problem solving skills.
Then they were asked to solve some math problems
and told the more they solved, the more they'd
be paid for being part of the study.
The researchers allowed them to report their
scores on the honor system, so they could
say they got whatever score they wanted- but
the researchers were secretly tracking their
actual progress.
Finally, the participants were given some
creative word-association problems.
The people who lied about their math scores
all did better than those who didn't.
The researchers go on to say that it's possible
that dishonesty is so widespread in society
because by acting dishonest we become more
creative, which lets us creatively rationalize
our dishonest
behavior, which makes us more creative- and
we just get into a big, messy loop.
Their study doesn't actually prove that, but
maybe they're just thinking creatively.
I was a nasty, horrible, dishonest kid- and
art and creative writing were my best subjects.
Hmmm.
What do you guys think?
Are creative people naturally dishonest?
Are you going to lie and cheat your way to
the great american novel?
Let me know down below and subscribe for more
DNews